انا اريد ان اقول ان طارق السويدان كغيره
ولكنه ابرز نفسه كداعيه
لتطوير الذات وداعيه يستخدم علوم الارنب
وغيرها في مرحله الثانيه ثم تكشف مع
الربيع العربي كشر عن انيابه وابانا عن
حجم التلون والتناقض الذي كان يعيش فيه
بين خطابه المعلن والمضمر في خطابك كشف عن
كل شيء نحن اليوم نتذكر مع الاحداث
الداميه للاسف في السودان والصراع العسكري
الدامي في السودان انه قبل سنوات قليله
كان يذهب الى هناك ويحاضر في الاخوان
المسلمين ويحاضر في التيارات الاسلاميه
التي كانت تدعى الى الخرطوم في ظل النظام
الاصولي وكان ينظر لنشر الخراب والدمار
والفوضى والقتل وتخريب البلدان بحسب
عبارات طارق سويدان نفسه في البلدان
العربيه في السودان وفي مصر وفي اليمن وفي
سوريا وفي غيرها كان لا يستبعد ان يقتل
عشرات الالاف
بدعم منه بتوجيه من هذا الذي اعلنه وهذا
الذي قاله فضلا عن ما يدار فالابيه السريه
لجماعات الاسلام السياسي والتي طارق
السويداني يطرح نفسه كقائد وعضو فيها في
اكثر من بلد ولذلك هو اضطر مجبرا للصمت في
الفتره الاخيره حتى يعيد انتاج نفسه ولكنه
يعني وقع في سيء اعماله حينما كان خروجه
في التهجم على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعلى الحرمين الشريفين ولذلك ليس غريبا
على طارق السويدان وهو متسق مع خطابه
وخطاب الصحوه الاسلاميه عند انا لفت
انتباهي موضوع انه صمت الفتره اللي راحت
كانهم يعني فهمتم كلام من كلامك عبد الله
انه يريد الظهور بمظهر جديد وهذا الامر لا
يخص طارق يبدو لي يعني كانها تكتيك عام او
خطه عامه لاعاده التمظهر من جديد اما نفس
الاسماء القديمه لكن تعود نفسها بثوب جديد
او بعناوين جديده او ابراز اسماء جديده لا
ادري هل انا مصيب في هذا الامر ام لا
والامر لكن دعنا نسمع جوابك على هذا الامر
ثم بتحدث عن تاريخ نقد الصحوه في السعوديه
هل تتفق معي او تختلف نعم انا اتفق في هذه
النقطه الخطاب الصحوي اليوم تلون بعده
الوان هو تلون على مسيرته وتغير على
مسيرته وهذه قصه طويله لكن اليوم الطروحات
الصحويه بدات تزيد من تلوناتها ومن
تغيراتها لتتوائم مع الانظمه السياسيه مع
التوجهات الجديده في العالم العربي ككل
وفي السعوديه ايضا يعني نحن جزء من هذا
العالم
هذه الجماعه لديها خبره قويه انها في
لحظات الانتباه لها وملاحقتها ومحاصرتها
تتلون بالوان متعدده وتغير تكتيكاتها بل
تغير خطابها فنحن نلاحظ ان هناك تغير في
الخطاب
وفي المفاهيم التي تطرح رايناها في الربيع
العربي بدل ما كانوا يطرحون الحاكميه
والجاهليه في الربيع العربي يطرحون
العداله والمساواه والديمقراطيه والثوره
اليوم يطرحون المفاهيم الجديده في العالم
التطوير الذاتي
البودكاست هذه على تلك على مستوى المفاهيم
وهذه على مستوى الوسائل ترى كل كاسيت
وذهبوا الى البودكاست تركوا الكتب وذهبوا
الى المدونات
نزلوا المستوى اللي ما يسمى باللهجه
السعوديه البثوث هذه البث المباشر في
تويتر وفي غيره لغه الخطاب تغيرت ولكن
المضامين والافكار واحده والهدف والغايه
واحده التغلغل في الدوله ونحن عندنا في
السعوديه تجربه صريحه منذ نهايه الخمسينات
وبدايه الستينات كيف تغلغلوا في المجتمع
وفي المؤسسات هم يصنعون الشيء ذاته اليوم
ولكن باساليب مختلفه وبطرائق مختلفه كما
يجري في غير السعوديه من البلدان ايضا هل
هل يحق لي طرحه ولا يعتبر يمكن شاطح شوي
ممكن واحد
يتفق مع اجنده طارق السويدان السياسيه
والاجتماعيه ما عدا بين قوسين العداء
للدوله السعوديه ما عدا العداء للدوله
السعوديه هذه يختلف ويختلف بعنف مع طارق
السودان بس في بقيه الامور الاجتماعيه
والثقافيه ورؤيه العالم ورؤيه السياسه
ربما يتفق مع طارق يعني هل ممكن اقرا لشخص
شيء بهذا المعنى ولا نشاط احد ولا شيء هذا
الاصل الاصل في خطابات جماعات الاسلام
السياسي انها متفقه على معاداه الانظمه
السياسيه ومن معادات الانظمه السياسيه
العداء الاكبر يتوجه للسعوديه لكن هناك
تيارات لا تختلف مع جماعه الاخوان او مع
القاعده الا في مساله تكفير الدوله
السعوديه او تكفير الانظمه الحاكم ثم
التكفير اقصد فيه في يعني شخصيات او ثقافه
ممكن تكفير الا الدفاع الشرس عن الدوله
السعوديه وعن الحكم السعودي في مقابل من
ينتقص او يتهجم منه لكن انا
ولذلك موقفه من الترفيه موقفه من العلاقات
ولذلك انا اقول لك ان خطاب التشدد وخطاب
التطرف في اصله واحد والخلاف على مساله
الحكم الذي ذكرت انت بعض تفاصيلها وخلافهم
في مساله واحده اما بقيه المسائل فالاتفاق
والاشتراك قائم بين جميع المتطرفين وهو
مخترق للجماعات يعني الاخواني يتفق في
موضوع المراه
مع السرور يتفق مع
القاعدي يتفق مع الداعشي يتفهم متفقون على
اختلاف تياراتهم وان بدا بينهم بعض العداء
على مسائل التطرف والتشدد التي من مظاهرها
الترفيه والسياحه وبناء اقتصاديات جديده
في الانفتاح في البلدان هذا هم يتفقون
جميعا لكن ايضا لان نفس التكتيكات الصحويه
واحده ومتعديه ومتجاوزه للجماعات
يحسنون اخفاء هذا او ابرازه اذا ذهبوا
للخارج